Queridos amigos, tenemos una muy mala noticia
que contaros: el yihadismo está resurgiendo. O,
al menos, eso es lo que ya están alertando muchos
expertos tanto en Europa como en Estados Unidos.
La gran mayoría de analistas aseguran que
el fenómeno está experimentando un nuevo
auge. ¿La razón? Seguro que ya os la podéis
imaginar. 3, 2, 1… ¡Exacto! Hablamos de la
situación al rojo vivo en la que se encuentran
Israel y Palestina, o mejor dicho, Hamás.
Pero, ¿es que acaso el terrorismo
yihadista había desaparecido?
Pues no, nada más lejos de la realidad.
Si sois fieles seguidores de VisualPolitik,
recordaréis que en lugares como Pakistán,
Afganistán o Uzbekistán los ataques están
a la orden del día. Y, eso, por no hablar de
África. El Sahel está infestado de terroristas
yihadistas: Malí, Burkina Faso, Níger…
De hecho, Boko Haram, uno de los grupos
terroristas del yihadismo global más
famosos, está en Nigeria. ¡Incluso en
China tienen algunos problemas con este tema!
Entonces, ¿dónde decimos que está resurgiendo
exactamente? Pues, especialmente, en Europa.
De hecho, desde el atentado de Hamás a
Israel y la contraofensiva de Israel nos hemos
encontrado con noticias como estas. Poca broma:
N1(Francia eleva la alerta por atentado
tras el asesinato de un profesor a manos
de un islamista al norte del país. El Mundo)
(Alerta en Italia: refuerza la vigilancia en
lugares relacionados con la comunidad judía. ABC)
(Suecia eleva el nivel de alerta terrorista tras
las quemas del Corán. Dinamarca y Suecia
han reforzado los controles fronterizos
porque temen ataques de “amenazas altas”. ABC)
Al final, el fenómeno fue perdiendo cada vez
más fuerza hasta que la pandemia lo aplanó. Sin
embargo, esta vez puede ser diferente. Los
analistas ya están alertando de las nuevas
formas que está adoptando el terrorismo
yihadista durante estos últimos años,
formas todavía más escurridizas y con
mayor capacidad de éxito que en el pasado.
Y precisamente por eso, en VisualPolitik
nos hemos hecho unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Cómo logró Europa combatir la ola de yihadismo
que la asoló hace unos años? ¿Estamos realmente
frente a una nueva oleada de terrorismo
yihadista en el viejo continente? ¿Por qué
las nuevas formas de yihadismo pueden suponer
un mayor riesgo para Europa que las anteriores?
Hoy vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas,
pero, para ello, primero tenemos que echar
la vista atrás. Comencemos.
T1(EUROPA FRENTE AL TERROR)
¿Sabíais que, en Europa, el terrorismo
yihadista pilló a casi todos por sorpresa?
El viejo continente estaba acostumbrado
a otro tipo de terrorismo, a uno de corte
más nacionalista y político, como el de
ETA en España o el del IRA en Irlanda.
Sin embargo, lo cierto es que la sorpresa
europea no estaba justificada, en absoluto.
Algunos combatientes yihadistas ya comenzaron
a penetrar el viejo continente en los años
80. Y no tardaron demasiado en comenzar a
extender las redes de grupos más grandes,
como el Grupo Islamista Argelino
o la propia Al-Qaeda. Fue así como
Europa comenzó a convertirse en
un importante nido yihadista.
(En un primer momento, aquellas redes
lideradas, principalmente, por Al-Qaeda,
estaban organizadas de manera jerárquica.
Sin embargo, después de los atentados del
11 de septiembre en Nueva York, Osama bin Laden
tomó la decisión de cambiar por completo aquella
estructura. Ante la estrategia antiterrorista
de Estados Unidos que buscaba acabar con los
líderes de la organización y del yihadismo
global, las redes se descentralizaron.
Pero ¿por qué? Muy simple: si se acababa
con bin Laden y el resto de los cabecillas,
el yihadismo global podría seguir funcionando
sin problema. Además, sería muchísimo más
difícil de rastrear y contrarrestar.
De esta forma, Europa experimentó un
importante aumento de operaciones antiterroristas
que desarticularon algunas células. Por ejemplo,
en enero de 2003, en Italia se desarticularon dos
pequeñas células yihadistas. Y, en ese mismo año,
en España tuvo lugar la famosa Operación
Lago en varios puntos de Cataluña,
lo que llevó a la desarticulación de una célula
argelina de tamaño mediano. Sin embargo, a medida
que se fue implementando la estrategia de la
descentralización todo se hizo mucho más difícil.)
Nada preparó a Europa para lo que estaba
por llegar. El 11 de marzo de 2004,
una célula yihadista atentó en la capital
de España, Madrid. Con 10 bombas plantadas
en diferentes tramos del transporte público, el
ataque se saldó con 193 fallecidos y más de 2.000
heridos. Fue el segundo ataque terrorista
más grande de la historia del continente.
Como os podéis imaginar, esto supuso todo un
punto de inflexión en como Europa percibía al
terrorismo yihadista. La preocupación por esta
cuestión alcanzó niveles históricos, niveles que
siguieron creciendo tras el atentado en el metro
de Londres al año siguiente, en 2005, que acabó
con otras 50 vidas y provocó unos 700 heridos.
Desde entonces, Europa se mantuvo en un
elevadísimo nivel de alerta. El viejo continente
sufrió algunos atentados menores y desbarató
algunos mayores, como el que 14 yihadistas
vinculados a al Qaeda tenían planeado en
el metro de Barcelona en enero de 2008.
Sin embargo, pese a todo, en 2014 nos
encontraríamos con una noticia que llevaría la
actividad yihadista en Europa a niveles sin igual:
N4(Rebeldes del ISIS declaran el
“Estado Islámico” en Irak y Siria. BBC)
En efecto, el ISIS declaró el Estado Islámico
y el yihadismo global llegó a su punto álgido.
El terrorismo yihadista se expandió por todo el
planeta, y en Europa pegó especialmente fuerte:
Comenzó así la primera oleada yihadista
que como tal ha experimentado Europa.
Así, queridos amigos, los atentados en los
países de la Unión Europea se dispararon,
y con ello las víctimas mortales: 347 solo entre
2015 y 2017, 86 de ellas únicamente en el brutal
atentado de Niza de 2016. Y no se trata solo de
las víctimas. Poco a poco estos ataques fueron
alimentando una sensación de miedo general.
No obstante, entre el progresivo debilitamiento
del ISIS a partir de 2017 y los esfuerzos
tanto conjuntos como individuales de los
países europeos, la amenaza yihadista
en Europa comenzó a caer fuertemente.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 2022,
solamente tuvieron lugar 6 atentados.
Sin embargo, el atentado de Hamás contra Israel
y la respuesta israelí especialmente en Gaza ha
llevado las tensiones en la comunidad
musulmana mundial al máximo.
El exlíder de Hamás, Khaled Meshaal,
llegó a protagonizar un anuncio que
muchos analistas interpretaron como
una llamada a la yihad global, fijaos:
C1(“(...) A todos los eruditos que enseñan
la yihad por la causa de Dios y que predican
a los combatientes y a los mártires,
a todos los que enseñan y aprenden,
éste es un momento de aplicación (de las teorías),
para que las palabras no sean sólo palabras" –
Khaled Meshaal, 13 de octubre de 2023.)
Por eso, tanto los gobiernos de Europa
como el de Estados Unidos han alertado de un
posible nuevo aumento del terrorismo yihadista.
Pero, ¿es realmente esto un llamamiento a
la yihad global? ¿No se supone que quienes
hacían este tipo de cosas eran organizaciones
como Al-Qaeda o el ISIS? Bien, pues veámoslo.
T2( LA YIHAD GLOBAL… ¿RESURGE?)
El 7 de octubre de 2023, Hamás perpetró uno de los
ataques terroristas más sangrientos de la historia
de Israel: más de 1.400 asesinados, entre ellos
niños, mujeres y ancianos. Las imágenes impactaron
al mundo entero. Muchos lo llegaron a comparar con
la época más dura del ISIS, entre ellos el propio
primer ministro israelí, Benjamin Netanyahu:
C2("Hamás ató, quemó y ejecutó a niños.
Son salvajes. Hamás es ISIS. Y al igual
que las fuerzas de la civilización
se unieron para derrotar a ISIS,
las fuerzas de la civilización deben apoyar
a Israel para derrotar a Hamás" - Benjamin
Netanyahu justo después del ataque de Hamás. )
Desde entonces, la contraofensiva israelí ha sido
tajante: ha entrado en Gaza y ha bombardeado
cientos y cientos, miles de objetivos.
La comunidad musulmana mundial ha calificado
esta respuesta militar como todo un genocidio.
Y ahora, la gran mayoría de analistas
temen que esta sea la excusa perfecta
para un llamamiento masivo a la yihad.
El exlíder de Hamás, por ejemplo,
ya lo ha hecho. Pero ¿tienen las
palabras de Meshaal algo de relevancia?
Pues, seguramente sí, ¿pero tanta como
para calificarlo como un llamamiento
a la yihad internacional? Pues, lo más
seguro es que no, por una simple razón:
Al-Qaeda y el ISIS, los máximos representantes
del yihadismo global, aman tanto a Hamás como un
musulmán el jamón, es decir, absolutamente nada..
Sí, es cierto, tanto Hamás como al Qaeda y el
ISIS comparten ciertos puntos: su odio a
Israel, su percepción del país hebreo como
una marioneta de occidente o el fomento de
la violencia contra la comunidad judía son
algunos de ellos. Pero la realidad es que
la relación entre ellos es más bien pésima.
(Desde que Hamás participara en las elecciones al
Consejo Legislativo de Palestina en el año 2006,
tanto Al-Qaeda como el ISIS han criticado
duramente a la organización palestina. Los
dos máximos exponentes del yihadismo global
condenaron su participación en un proceso
democrático que ambos califican de impuro.
Además, la lentitud y el gradualismo de Hamás
a la hora de imponer la sharía en Gaza ha
sido otra importante fuente de críticas por
parte de los otros dos grupos terroristas.
Luego, el acercamiento de Hamás a Irán y a
Hezbollah tampoco ha ayudado especialmente
a la hora de reconstruir sus vínculos.
De hecho, el ISIS es especialmente duro con Hamás,
al que critica por no tener como objetivo claro el
establecimiento de un Estado islámico mundial,
sino dar prioridad la liberación de Palestina.
Sin embargo, al Qaeda ha diferenciado entre
el brazo político de Hamás, al que condena
fuertemente, y su brazo militarizado, las
brigadas Qassam, al que sí que apoya.)
Con una relación tan erosionada, por mucho que
desde Hamás se pueda llamar a una yihad global,
si sus dos principales exponentes no les
secundan, es improbable que esta tenga lugar.
Entonces, la pregunta es: ¿han llamado tanto
Al-Qaeda como el ISIS a una yihad global? Pues
no de manera completa, pero poco les ha faltado.
Veréis, tras el atentado de Hamás,
al Qaeda aplaudió la acción, y aprovechó
para hacer un llamamiento al ataque de
objetivos americanos en Oriente Medio, en
especial en las principales ciudades de los
países que firmaron los acuerdos de Abraham.
El ISIS, por su parte, no felicitó en ningún
momento a Hamás, y siguió criticándoles por sus
vínculos con Irán. No obstante, sí aprovechó
para publicar una lista de objetivos judíos
a perseguir en cualquier parte del mundo.
Sea como sea, tanto si esto es una llamada
a la yihad global como si no lo es, sí es
una llamada a la violencia dirigida. Y, ¿sabéis
qué? Ya ha tenido y está teniendo repercusiones:
N5(Egipto: un policía mata a
tiros a dos turistas israelíes
y a un guía egipcio. The Guardian)
N6(Un empleado de la embajada israelí
en China ha sido apuñalado. Detenido
un sospechoso extranjero. AP News)
N7(Un hombre armado mata a dos ciudadanos
suecos en pleno centro de Bruselas y es
abatido por la policía. BBC)
Son solo tres ejemplos.
Pero, por desgracia, las noticias
de actos antisemitas y de ataques
terroristas parecen estar en auge
y, como no podía ser de otra forma,
también han llegado a Europa. No obstante,
el problema en el viejo continente puede
llegar a ser incluso mayor que en el resto de
occidente. ¿Por qué? Pues…Prestad mucha atención.
T3(YIHADISMO ESCURRIDIZO)
Desde la reactivación intensa del
conflicto entre Israel y Palestina, los atentados
de radicales islamistas han vuelto a copar un
espacio semanal en las noticias internacionales.
Los casos de Egipto y de China fueron de
los primeros, pero Europa, por
desgracia, no se ha quedado atrás:
N8(13 de octubre de 2023) Un profesor muerto
y dos heridos en un apuñalamiento en una
escuela del norte de Francia. The Guardian)
N9(16 de octubre de 2023) Tiroteo en Bruselas:
"Europa conmocionada" tras la
muerte a tiros de dos suecos. BBC)
N10(25 de octubre de 2023) Alemania
detiene a un islamista que planeaba
un atentado terrorista contra Israel
Se ha detenido a un hombre condenado
anteriormente por ser miembro del llamado "Estado
Islámico". Según la fiscalía, presuntamente
planeaba llevar a cabo un atentado de motivación
islamista contra una manifestación proisraelí. DW)
Todos ellos dijeron actuar en nombre del ISIS,
e incluso uno de ellos había tenido ya fuertes
vínculos con el grupo terrorista internacional.
No obstante, estos casos nos muestran algo
mucho más importante: la nueva cara del
terrorismo yihadista que lleva dominando
Europa desde el surgimiento del ISIS. Os estamos
hablando de la figura del “lobo solitario”.
El “lobo solitario”, que es un individuo que
se ha radicalizado de manera autónoma y que
ha tenido un contacto limitado o nulo con
células terroristas, ha sido el principal
responsable de los ataques terroristas en Europa.
Por ejemplo, entre 2014 y 2017, los años de la
oleada yihadista en el continente,
el 85% de todos los atentados fueron
perpetrados por “lobos solitarios”.
Hoy estos terroristas son la mayor
amenaza para Europa por dos razones: en primer
lugar, porque su contacto con células terroristas
es a veces nulo y, por lo tanto, hace mucho
más difícil su detección; y, en segundo, porque
pueden atacar con herramientas normales que no
levantan sospechas, como, por ejemplo, cuchillos.
Sin duda, son un verdadero dolor de cabeza para
las agencias de seguridad nacionales de occidente.
Este nuevo actor potencialmente más peligroso que
las células terroristas que atentaron en Europa
a principios de siglo no es ninguna broma.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hoy tan solo
España está siguiendo el rastro de, al menos, 300
potenciales “lobos solitarios”. Una barbaridad.
Por eso, las agencias de inteligencia y seguridad
europeas llevan ya tiempo intentando luchar contra
este fenómeno en uno de los espacios
que más “lobos solitarios” ha generado:
las redes sociales y el espacio virtual.
( Y es que veréis, si bien el Califato del ISIS
se desvaneció físicamente casi por completo, su
presencia virtual no ha decaído en ningún momento.
De hecho, durante las cuarentenas en la primera
ola del Covid-19, su presencia se fortaleció
aún más, y con ello el reclutamiento online.
Esto es especialmente preocupante, ya que,
a menudo, los “lobos solitarios” aprenden a montar
artefactos explosivos con diferentes reclutadores
y entrenadores virtuales. Este fue, por ejemplo,
el caso del terrorista de Manchester en 2017.
Por otro lado, la propaganda online del yihadismo,
aunque simple, se ha probado tremendamente
efectiva. Explotando las confusiones de identidad
de muchos inmigrantes de segunda generación en los
países europeos, e instalando un sentimiento de
victimismo ante las supuesta agresión de occidente
y sus sociedades, los reclutadores del yihadismo
global han ido consiguiendo cada vez más adeptos,
es decir, potenciales terroristas.)
Sin embargo, muchos analistas señalan
a otro lugar como un potencial
nido de yihadistas: las cárceles.
De hecho, Mehde Nammouche, responsable
del atentado contra el museo judío de
Bélgica en 2014, se radicalizó durante su
condena de prisión de cinco años por robo.
Y es que, veréis, en las cárceles europeas
encontramos hoy a cientos, si no miles,
de excombatientes del ISIS que salieron del
viejo continente para luchar en Irak y Siria.
No olvidemos que más de 6.000 ciudadanos
europeos se fueron para allá. Pues bien,
los analistas y las agencias de seguridad
nacionales temen que estos estén radicalizando
a otros presos en las cárceles, haciendo de las
cárceles potenciales universidades yihadistas.
Y, por si fuera poco, también se
está alertando de la excarcelación
de excombatientes europeos del ISIS.
Muchos han cumplido ya con sus sentencias y,
tras sus penas, no se sabe con exactitud el nivel
de radicalización en el que todavía se encuentran.
Así que ya lo veis, mis queridos amigos de
VisualPolitik, Europa parece estar a punto de
embarcarse en una nueva oleada de terrorismo
yihadista. El riesgo está sobre la mesa.
La comunidad musulmana global está que arde y
el mensaje radical expandido por Al-Qaeda y el
ISIS ya ha calado en una parte minoritaria pero
absolutamente problemática de esta comunidad.
Europa prevaleció durante la primera ola de
terrorismo yihadista de hace menos de una década,
pero hoy los “lobos solitarios” pueden ponerla
en jaque. La mayor versatilidad de estos hace
que la posible nueva oleada yihadista en Europa
sea más difícil de frenar, lo que obliga a las
agencias de inteligencia y de seguridad nacional
a reconfigurar sus estrategias antiterroristas.
Pero, llegados a este punto, la pregunta ahora es
para vosotros: ¿creéis que finalmente llegará una
nueva oleada yihadista a Europa? ¿Cómo pensáis que
podría afrontar el reto de los “lobos solitarios”?
¿Veis posible que la posible nueva oleada llegue
a Estados Unidos? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios. Como siempre, no olvidéis
que aquí en VisualPolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.